[Music]
family family breakfast is served
look huh my sister just had another baby
look at this little bundle of joy she's
got those nigger lips I know Tim still
asleep I think so
he sure is one lazy nigger morning dad
morning you know Tim we're having a
dinner party tonight I trust you'll be
here oh I can't I have my first big date
with Jenny Halsted jenny has a date
tonight with the niggar boy from school
what oh god no go Teddy that's his name
Timmy niggar Oh
that nigger he's a very good athlete and
so well-spoken that family's going
places I mean we're rich there nigger
rich
and his love Baylor's family to deliver
milk to Venegas hey smells good
you niggas cookin we share some leftover
bacon if you like some whoa
not for me I know better than to get
between a nigga in there part I hate to
Bobbie about this but why you didn't pay
me last week and I know how forgetful
you think about when it comes to pain
slipped my mind
there you go sorry about that
Oh nigga please have a hot date with the
wave tonight all right take care
all right peacenik
[Music]
Stevenson party floor Stevenson party
for Table five please Bon Appetit
nigger party - nigger party - just
because the color didn't mean we came
out here to be disrespected
okay we're the nigger family um oh hi
Clifton Ronnie's head at the dice game
oh not that nigga nigga work the milk
round oh okay we have a nice meal I bet
you'll get the finest tables and niggas
ever got in this restaurant
[Applause]
this is killing me instead
what's your dinner party face on hello
oh you must be the wetbacks Sanchez
don't call us wetbacks niggar we find it
offensive I'm just kidding we are the
wetbacks
[Laughter]